delicious is not a word we normally use
to describe hospital foods but one chef
is changing perceptions of what
cafeteria food can be with the help of
some international cuisine chef Kobe
Smith revamped the menu at Arkansas
Heart Hospital and his signature disc
dish is authentic ramen Adriana Diaz
visited the Little Rock Hospital to see
how the menu is attracting more than
just patients and employees we actually
work on the campus of Arkansas
Children's Hospital so you came from
another hospital to this hospital to
have lunch since we've been doing this
we've had thousands and thousands of
people come to this hospital for one
reason only and that's just to eat our
food three days a week
chef Coby Smith dishes out what's
arguably the most authentic Japanese
ramen in town so do you always come when
they're serving ramen Monday Wednesday
Friday just now all three days yes ma'am
sometimes on Fridays I'll get two
Ramin in Little Rock Raman in Little
Rock at a hospital it's right are y'all
doing up here for a few years chef Coby
has been turning around the hospital
kitchen good
after dr. Bruce Murphy the hospital CEO
said the food was too institutional food
that has been prepared elsewhere canned
and you open a bag and you served the
people after you warmed it up not fresh
food not vibrant food hospital food it's
hospital food and we wanted to change
that he demanded that ingredients be
crushed the food delicious oh and one
more thing he wanted to have authentic
Japanese ramen I was being a little bit
selfish because I love ramen noodles and
I figured everybody else would love
ramen he discovered his love for the
dish while traveling in Asia I didn't
think twice about where the best place
in the world was for him to learn how to
cook ramen is Tokyo we got to go to
Tokyo so for a week chef Coby visited
the doctor's favorite ramen shops and
met with their chefs taking notes and
videos along the way these guys do the
same job every day over and over again
for 30 40 50 years they take their craft
so literally and there so it's an honor
for them once back in Arkansas he spent
eight months trying to turn his research
into ramen starting with the
all-important broth it's like a small
child you have to nurture it and watch
it and make sure all the ingredients are
the same can you even learn how to make
authentic ramen in one week no you can't
do it but you do the best you can with
what you have we're in the South so you
know we have a southern twist to a lot
of our ramen dishes twists like crawfish
and okra but today was pork belly day I
was very skeptical little rock food
critic Kevin shaylen resisted the
concept of hospital made ramen until he
tried it if a restaurant was serving
this kind of ramen would you rate it as
highly yeah you know just because it's
served in a hospital I don't rate it any
differently
it is good ramen so good that on ramen
days parking becomes a problem it's been
so successful that I can't get to my my
ramen shop because there are other
people in line that's a rare problem in
the realm of hospital food for CBS this
morning Adriana Diaz Little Rock